foreign
hey good afternoon guys thanks for
taking my call you bet what's up
so
um I make a lot of money I've been with
the same job for about four years I'm 26
years old
but I recently this past year uh have
just been struggling with some mental
health issues
uh everything at work seems to be
negative I contribute a lot I feel like
I'm doing my job well but the
organization itself is not doing all
that well but all the negativity really
trickles down it's a lot of yelling it's
a lot of nothing's ever right hold up
hold on a second who's yelling
a lot of a leadership team
okay and and what what else is going on
I heard that you you feel like you're
doing your job you're pulling your
weight you got some teammates that
aren't or maybe your leader isn't what's
going on there
right exactly so I work in Enterprise
technology sales B2B and
it can be interesting the way that some
of these
um
deals Shape Up and sometimes you'll have
years where it'll be very dependent on
one or two transactions so you're
basically All or Nothing
um and I've had a good run so far but
it's it's spotty there's things that you
can't control you could be really good
at your job but your attainment might
not reflect that sure um and I think
that's what's going on across the
organization and especially the economy
the way that it is
um it's it's been challenging this past
year especially so what does it mean to
you when you say I'm having mental
health issues what does that look like
feel like
um just every day that I wake up
during the work week it's another day
that I just
would rather not mutter through and just
kind of going through the motions losing
motivation yeah
um really just
struggling to keep my performance where
it was because I just don't feel valued
I don't feel like that's it I make any
sort of difference you nailed it all
right so the reason I ask this and I
don't I want us to be careful
um and and Nick this is not at you this
is this is to the larger audience as
well
um
I guess you could get into a debate
about whether that's mental health or
not I don't think that's what I would
call a mental health issue that right
there is just you aren't feeling valued
and you don't want to keep going into
that place and yet you got to right now
until you replace it and so there's
obligation
that is colliding with you know
exhaustion I would tell you you are
mentally and emotionally exhausted that
I know and and and so it's okay to use
the phrase mental health but I just want
to stipulate that you're okay
you just need a new location
uh you need a new gig
and so I don't know if you were calling
for permission on that you don't need it
from us but I think I'm looking if you
haven't already started looking I'm
looking because when I hear things like
they're yelling and it's just a nasty
culture that is rarely able I mean
rarely can you change that you having a
meeting with your leader is probably not
going to change that is that right
yeah that's correct um I am asking for
your permission now because I'm it's
tied to a financial predicament what's
the predicament
the predicament is I am under contract
to purchase a co-op
in Queens
um that I was hoping to close this month
but the contingency is there's a garage
spot that the owner of this Co-op has
that he needs to sell to somebody else
in the building and I do not want it for
the price that he's asking so this is
going to
drag out it seems for at least another
few months if not you know half a year
so if I go and start looking for jobs
now and potentially receive an offer and
I'm looking to make a move that might
affect my mortgage lending ability
because of your change in income
well potentially because of my change in
income but also uh just because of my
tenure that doesn't matter Nick
you can always buy a co-op or or I would
not make a decision
about a co-op
I would make the decision about my life
and this work situation is much bigger
than the co-op situation this is about
your livelihood your life the way you
live it you're having a hard time
getting out of bed so I would the job
decision is the one that I'm focused on
not the co-op
what are you making right now Nick
uh so my income varies a little bit
because I'm in sales but I the average
of the past three years is about 140
Grand
and you don't think you could make 140
Grand in Tech sales at a different
company
no I definitely think I could
um it's just a matter of
I'm scared to make a jump because I
don't want it to negatively affect the
mortgage process on this Co-op and have
this fall through because I think it's a
big opportunity financially for me
to finally own something and have an
asset
um and I'm young and I'm trying to get
into the real estate game I'm not really
passionate about sex sales I make a lot
of money doing it but I'm really not
um stimulated by it the way that I would
lecture are you going to live in this
Co-op
yes okay do you have any debt
no debt okay
well what's the worst case scenario here
let's say the deal the mortgage doesn't
get approved because you have this
change in income or whatever what
happens
I can't close on the co-op and I'm stuck
living in live in a very small apartment
right now in the basement of one of my
dad's rental properties uh The Price is
Right I'm living for free I've been
living here for about 10 or 11 months
the initial plan was only to live here
for a couple until I could close on
something it's a sweet deal in New York
well do you lose any money if you back
out of this deal because of the mortgage
falling through
um couple thousand bucks but nothing
crazy okay so this doesn't it's not
gonna tank your life it would stink
because you're really excited about this
but I'm with Canon I don't want to stick
in this job I hate for six months just
because of this Co-op deal yeah so I
would find another tech sales job if
that's what you need right now
eventually I think you need a whole new
career at least in a better environment
just to get stable just to get stable
then we can figure out what's next and
what career is right for you